you don't know what you're supposed to
do and somehow it all just comes
together and then you don't know why you
wouldn't have known it in the first
place
by studying geometry we can
think about our first principles think
about our underlying assumptions
and think about how we use reasoning
skills and logic skills to put those
arguments together
geometry itself is a way to think about
those
underlying assumptions and from those
assumptions just build up this huge body
of knowledge
and i don't think people understand that
big picture of how
all of this fits together and how it has
to be the way that it
is
we do a disservice to young people
by not teaching them all the steps in
mathematics
because it's liberating to know them
and by discarding euclid you have cut
them off from a way to understand
logic from which all accurate reasoning
and you've cut them off from also
understanding the beauty of the
relationships in nature
[Music]
most of you might experience your
geometry and other math classes to be
about calculation
and formulas and memorization but
in our study of geometry in particular
the study of euclidean geometry
the core question and concern is not so
much how
and how we calculate but rather why we
will be
looking at logic we'll be looking at
reasoning skills
we'll be getting into the mind of euclid
and trying to understand
how he put these pieces together how he
organized this
so i hope as we go forward in this
course that you'll
have that eureka moment where you can
understand how it all fits together
i'm thomas trelor and i am david murphy
this is our course in mathematics and
logic
let's begin